foreign
[Music]
it's 10 o'clock this is Sky News at 10
our top story former president Donald
Trump found to be a sexual abuser but a
jury rejects accusations he raped a
journalist in 1996. he's ordered to pay
five million dollars in Damages to e
Gene Carroll but dismisses the Civil
Trial as a Witch Hunt
also tonight the arrest of a former
prime minister fuels protests across
Pakistan with Imran Khan's supporters
being urged to shut down the country
the teenager who stabbed a 14 year old
boy seven times with a machete is handed
a life sentence
in Moscow a muted parade to celebrate
Victory Day as the Russian president
declares his country is at war with the
West
preparing for power but the labor leader
repeatedly refuses to rule out a
coalition with the lib Dems Plus
[Music]
Eurovision super fans descend on
Liverpool for the world's biggest
musical spectacle
and we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages that's coming up
in our press preview from 10 30.
[Music]
hello there good evening he is the
Republican front runner for the U.S
presidential election next year who
already faces criminal charges for
making hush money payments to a porn
star and tonight Donald Trump has been
found to be a sexual abuser by a jury at
a Civil Trial in New York in a unanimous
decision the nine jurors decided that he
did not rape magazine columnist e Gene
Carroll in the 1990s Mr Trump described
the verdict as a disgrace part of what
he called the greatest Witch Hunt of all
time well a U.S correspondent James
Matthews is outside the U.S District
Court in Manhattan James
hello Anna thank you very much indeed
yes you know in 1996 when e Gene Carroll
bumped in to Donald Trump outside a New
York Department so she says that was the
moment when her life changed she was
brutally attacked she said and
thereafter was mentally scarred it was
in 2019 that she told the story of what
she said was a rape she brought that
story to this court the jury weren't
with her on that specific charge but
they did agree that she had been
sexually abused by Donald Trump she left
this court five million pounds richer in
compensatory damages and with Donald
Trump branded a sex offender
she's the woman who claimed that Donald
Trump raped her a New York jury wasn't
with Eugene Carroll on that her Central
claim but it did find that he had
sexually abused her
we're very happy said her lawyer the
client five million dollars richer you
have so much respect for you
hijin cattle is a former magazine advice
columnist she told this course she was
attacked by Donald Trump in the
mid-1990s following a chance encounter
outside this Manhattan Department Store
Eugene Carroll said she bumped into
Donald Trump as she was leaving the
store he recognized her as an advice
columnist he said he was buying a gift
for a female friend could she advise him
the two ended up in the lingerie section
of the Department Store Eugene Carroll
said he led her to a dressing room
Pinter against the wall and sexually
assaulted her a black and white
photograph that we've marked as DJ t23
Donald Trump claimed he'd never met his
accuser and that she wasn't his type
her lawyer said this photo from the 80s
contradicted both claims left of picture
is Donald Trump second left is Eugene
Carroll in a deposition to the court he
appeared to confuse her with his ex-wife
Marla Maples I don't even know who the
woman let's say I don't know who it's
Marla
you say Marvel's in this photo that's
Marla yeah that's that's my wife which
one woman are you pointing to I know
here
oh the person you just pointed to
was oh
yeah employers for aging Carl said
confusing her with his ex-wife sure she
was very much his time and when you're a
star they let you do it you can do
anything whatever you want and they
played the so-called Access Hollywood
tape in which Donald Trump boasts of
groping women it's true the stars that
they can grab women by the well that's
what it's if you look over the last
million years I guess that's been
largely too not always but largely true
unfortunately or fortunately
in the words of his accuser's lawyer
it's who Donald Trump is how he thinks
and what he does
eating Carol hugged her legal team in
court as the jury verdicts were read out
Donald Trump gave his reaction on his
social media platform stating I have
absolutely no idea who this woman is the
verdict is a disgrace a continuation of
the greatest Witch Hunt of all time
this isn't a criminal case unlike the
charges laid against Donald Trump
earlier this year over hush Money Paid
to a porn star this civil case won't
result in any prison sentence but he is
liable for financial loss and then there
is the price he will pay politically
ahead of a presidential campaign what
price the reputation as a sex offender
James Matthews Sky News in New York
well you heard the reaction of Donald
Trump that was amplifier Amplified
outside caught by his lawyer Joe
takapina who called this court case at
his grace let's listen now to the lawyer
for Donald Trump
well he's affirming his belief
as many people are they cannot get a
fair trial in New York City
um based on the approval and um I think
one could argue that that's probably an
accurate assessment based on what
happened today
um and uh you know again it's something
that you know we're very confident on
these televisions here
Donald Trump planning an appeal of this
juries finding he is a man who has
continually throughout a number of
criminal investigations
called himself
a victim of a political Witch Hunt
spoken about a justice system a
political system that has targeted him
he has played the victimhood card with
some success he has enjoyed a bounce in
the polls on the back of it enjoy the
bounce in fundraising but one does
wonder how this particular case and the
particular offenses being looked at
inside this Manhattan Court will play
will play into a presidential campaign
because after all Donald Trump has been
labeled here a sex offender he himself
recognizes the stigma that that carries
across Society on video he acknowledged
that to be called a rape a rapist to be
accused of rape was the worst charge he
recognizes the stigma associated with
sexual abuse with sex offending he has
been tarred with that brush in this
court it will be a challenge for him
carrying that forward amongst the
concern
burden of legal barring of legal baggage
that he already carries behind him
James Matthews live there in New York
thank you
the former Pakistani prime minister
Imran Khan was arrested today and
whisked Away by dozens of armed security
officers as he appeared in court on
corruption charges protests have erupted
in cities across the country with police
using tear gas and water cannon to quell
the demonstrations a summer moisten now
reports don't know
this is the moment Imran Khan was taken
into custody surrounded by a sea of
Rangers Pakistan's paramilitary force in
full riot gear
earlier guarded by his supporters Imran
Khan had arrived at Islamabad high court
for one of
127 court cases against him he says are
politically motivated
moments later Security Forces smashed
windows at the court to gain entry to
take him into custody of bemused Imran
Khan looking on as the drama unfolded
Imran Khan had predicted this as he set
off for court
this is my Pakistan it's not yours it's
our military you can't just shut our
mouths when we criticize you if there's
a warrant for my arrest simply hand it
to me and my lawyers and I'll hand
myself in I'm ready to go to jail
at the heart of this is a Face-Off
between Imran Khan and Pakistan's
powerful military he's accused them of
orchestrating a series of moves against
him his party members are raising
concerns for his safety longer he's in
there we feel that he'll be assassinated
and we feel that he'll be killed in
there or badly tortured The Crickets had
turned politicians party there he can
saf the party for justice is calling for
people to shut down Pakistan
these are scenes we have never witnessed
before in Pakistan civilians attacking a
military base women leading the way for
protesters
[Music]
a military rarely questioned with
unparalleled power this is the Pakistan
Army's General headquarters
hundreds Gathering outside the Army
Corps Commander's house in Lahore some
breaking in
Imran Khan an icon of Pakistan has
pitted himself and his supporters
against the most powerful institution of
Pakistan Simon Mawson Sky News
Jermaine cools was just 14 years old
when he was stabbed seven times with a
machete the youngest victim of knife
crime in London in 2021 today his
murderer himself 16 when he carried out
the crime was sentenced to at least 19
years behind bars in a rare televised
hearing Becky Cottrell has more
a humble child with a lot of dreams that
is how Jermaine Cole's family remember
the Beloved 14 year old he was stabbed
to death seven times with a machete
after becoming involved in a fight in
South London he managed to stand up with
the help of passers-by but his injuries
were too severe and he died later in
hospital
Marcus Walker was just 16 when he
repeatedly stabbed Jermaine he later
boasted about the killing in the lyrics
of a rap song he wrote this is yet
another case involving the senseless
murder of a young teenager committed
four reasons that no mature adult can
fathom
Jermaine cools was only 14 when you
killed him
he was the youngest victim of fatal
knife crime in London in 2021
Jermaine's father Julius cools says
Walker's sentence is far below what he
deserves I think it's ridiculous and I
think like um
gives more kids to do more killing and
after you killed someone at the age of
17 go to prison for 19 years this is
nothing
original like you can do whatever you
want to do and get away with it he plans
to appeal the sentence
we memorize Lord and look at the life of
Jermaine Jermaine was part of a big and
devoted family unable to find any
comfort in the judge's decision they
cherish their memories of a young boy
who was so loved Becky Cottrell Sky News
[Music]
just one Russian tank rumbled through
moscow's Red Square today a relic of
World War II that's hardly the show of
military might that Vladimir Putin would
have wanted on Russia's Victory Day
which celebrates the defeat of the Nazis
but the parade lacked in troops and
Hardware was compensated by the Russian
president's rhetoric as our Moscow
correspondent Diana magnate reports
it is always quite the spectacle never a
goose step out of place or a berry outed
line
but this was a slimmed Down Parade just
8 000 troops a lot fewer than last year
and much less military ships
because what Russia still has its leads
on the battlefield and not on Red Square
flanked by veterans this is a moment the
president enjoys the memory of World War
II is the Patriotic glue he uses to hold
his people together in a face of what
he's long described as a marauding and
decadent West
their goal and there's nothing new here
to achieve the disintegration and
destruction of our country to cross out
the results of World War II to finally
break the system of Global Security in
international law
there was a time when Western leaders
would take part in all of this but not
anymore this time just leaders from
former Soviet republics invited last
minute and not quite prepared to
relinquish old alliances some more
dependent on Russia than others
regular muscovites were kept well away
the parade canceled and another two
dozen cities
this is the closest the general public
here in Moscow get to this parade they
just see the hardware coming out of red
square right at the end real tail end of
the procession stuff not what they got
out of bed for this morning
so most watched Along on their mobile
phones
I think the bridge is nice and it's
necessary in Russia but some of the
vehicles that are used there may be used
in Ukraine
it's all the US and Ukraine's tricks our
grandfathers should have finished them
off better they should have finished
them off in 45 so that this wouldn't be
happening now
one soldier's mother meeting Vladimir
Putin clutching the picture of her son
killed in Ukraine
but there are so many more whose numbers
aren't yet counted on how many will
Russia remember when all this is done
magnese Sky News Moscow
for some of the tanks not in Red Square
today were on display in Kiev broken and
rusted and on a symbolic visit the head
of the EU commission Ursula vonder Lyon
stood alongside Ukraine's president
hours after another barrage of Russian
missiles Alex Rossi reports now from the
Ukrainian capital
as Dawn broke just hours before Russia's
Victory Day Parade explosion sounded
over the Ukrainian capital
the windows of buildings shaking
violently from the shock waves of
missiles intercepted
there have been more attacks in recent
days and president zelenski who met with
the leader of the European union says
it's another desperate sign that
Russia's war is failing
now the number of missiles is increasing
in my opinion the Russian Federation the
military political Authority need to
sell something to their society because
they aren't achieving anything
the strikes have been going on for
months in this Square rusting Russian
armor destroyed during the first wave of
the invasion
but despite the constant attacks the
resolve of this nation has not been
broken
and Ukraine is bracing itself for more
aerial attacks on its towns and cities
it's about to Stage a counter-offensive
after its military received extensive
supplies of Western ammunition and
equipment
many of the units will be doing the
fighting are still training for the
coming assaults and they are optimistic
they can win
we are in great spirits highly motivated
and we are training we have exercises up
to four hours per day and also training
at night
but a breakthrough will not be easy a
Frontline movement has been measured in
meters for months
an analysis of satellite imagery shows
Russia has used this time to build long
defenses across the front line
the first attack could be in the South
where Ukraine could try to break the
Russian land bridge to Crimea
it appears Russia is expecting this with
two lines of well-dug in trenches making
any advances difficult
[Applause]
but Ukraine knows success is vital
counter-offensive may be the only chance
it gets to change the dynamic on the
battlefield and guarantee continued
Western support
Alex Rossi Sky News Kiev
the labor leader sir kirst armor has
said that he's confident the party is on
course to win a majority at the next
general election but admits the hardest
work is now ahead of them Mr stalmer
refused seven times to explicitly rule
out the prospect of a deal with the
liberal democrats should his party fall
short of an outright majority he was
speaking to a political editor Beth
Rigby
today meeting his new labor Council
leaders happy enough
happy with the games made at last week's
local elections but all eyes on the
bigger test yet to come this is a very
good set of election results for us and
it puts us on course for a labor
majority every sofologist every expert
everyone that studies these numbers and
they've done them for decades say that
labor is based on these results not on
calls for an outright majority and you
keep saying that you are I think we are
I think if you look at where the
rabbit's been started back it up to read
what's happening in Scotland but look if
you're putting to me that we need to
kick on I completely accept that I'm
confident but I'm not complacent those
results when replicated nationally not
taking labor over the line so would this
leader consider deals with other parties
to help him get there you sat next to Ed
Davey at the coronation on Saturday so
man you can do business with well look
I'm going for an outright majority and
I'm often asked you know will you do a
deal with the SMP and I've been out
absolutely clear there are no terms in
which we would do a deal with the SMU I
want to push on to a labor majority what
about the lib dams well
during hypothetical s but you know we
what we are aiming for a labor majority
so you are ruling out a deal with the s
p on any terms but you're not ruling out
a deal with the lib Dems well as you
know with the asmp it's a fundamental
difference I do not believe in the
breakup and separation of the United
Kingdom just to be clear you're ruling
out any sort of arrangement with the s p
and you are not doing that with the
liberal Democrats I'm clear I'm pressing
on I want a labor majority government
workable majority but what of the
likelihood of that one to ten How likely
is it going to be that you will have a
majority labor government next year if
there's an election towards the top end
that's what we're going for
not yet ready to celebrate his chances
here
but the conservative party has little to
be pleased about either
[Music]
a year is a long time in politics Beth
Rigby Sky News in central London
the Metropolitan Police Commissioner
Mark Rowley has defended the way his
Force handled the coronation and pointed
to serious and reliable intelligence
that major disruption was being planned
but after the Met expressed regret for
the arrest of six anti-monarchy
protesters who were held for 16 hours
then released without charge the mayor
of London has now demanded an urgent
review here's our crime correspondent
modern Brunt
the commissioner described the
preemptive arrest of six
anti-monarchists as unfortunate but he
said it was the only use of tough new
anti-protest laws the group were
unloading placards from a van we were
informed once they found some luggage
straps that we were going to use to
secure those placards to control these
and bring them down to try the square
for protesting our supporters there that
we were to be detained under Section 3
of the public order act locking on and
we were then taken into custody or
between 16 and 17 hours
police said that on the eve of the
coronation they were so worried about
disruption the Home Secretary and the
mayor were given late-night intelligence
briefings
the commissioner wrote in the evening
standard we found people in possession
of possible lock-on devices and people
that appeared to be purporting to be
stewards of the event in possession of
plastic bottles containing white paint
which we believe were specifically to be
used to criminally disrupt the
procession and resulted in arrests for
going equipped to commit criminal damage
in a letter to the commissioner the
mayor of London one of his political
Masters said he was grateful there was
no disruption that he demanded urgent
answers to his concerns over the arrest
of those six Republic supporters
the new laws were rushed through last
week in the wake of regular disruption
caused by climate activists just stop
oil police now have powers to arrest
protesters for blocking transport hubs
and energy installations and to search
them without Reasonable Suspicion as
we've seen over the last weeks and
months there are lots of instances of
people's day-to-day lives being
seriously disrupted by protesters and
people have rightly asked well why isn't
that being stopped so it is right that
the government gives the police the
powers to deal with those things but
again those are operational decisions
for the police on the ground at the time
why am I being arrested over the
coronation weekend police arrested 64
people 52 of them suspected of plotting
disruption Martin brunt Sky News
Scotland Yard
powerful explosions echoed around Gaza
early this morning as Israeli warplanes
targeted senior commanders in Islamic
Jihad the strip's second largest
militant group Palestinian officials say
at least 10 civilians were killed
including women and children and three
high-ranking militants as our Middle
East correspondent Aleister bunkel
explains
the Israeli airstrikes began just after
two o'clock in the morning 40 aircraft
struck targets across the Gaza Strip
the focus was the homes of three
commanders from Palestinian Islamic
Jihad
Israel says that they had been
responsible for attacks on Israel in
recent weeks
weapons factories and storage facilities
were also hit
Four Women and four children were among
the dead twenty were wounded some of
those also civilians
the funerals were held in Gaza this
afternoon
lives next door to one of the Islamic
Jihad Commanders two of her daughters
Dania and Iman were killed when the
missiles hit the building Iman was 16
and Dania was 19 and due to get married
in July
foreign
says it was a precise targeted military
operation and described the Islamic
Jihad commanders as Kingpin terrorists
but they did admit that civilians had
also been killed
Israel's prime minister said that the
operation was not yet over
the whole episode
tonight in Israeli drone killed two
Islamic Jihad militants in Gaza that
they said were planning to launch
missiles on Israel
Tel Aviv has opened public bomb shelters
Israel is braced for a retaliation
Aleister bunkel Sky News in Jerusalem
a giant barge which will be used to
house Asylum Seekers has arrived in
Falmouth in Cornwall the Bibby Stockholm
which will be refurbished to house
around 500 migrants is expected to be
moved into position off the coast of
Dorset in the next few weeks Portland
Port where it's set to be docked has
reportedly removed its cruise ship
schedule from its website in a bid to
deter anti-migrant protesters
patients will be able to receive
prescription medicines without seeing a
GP under new plans announced by the
government to ease the strain on
surgeries under the proposals
pharmacists will be able to write
prescriptions for common conditions such
as earaches sore throats and urinary
tract infections similar schemes are
already running in Scotland and Wales
and Manchester City fought back to end
the first leg of their Champions League
semi-final level with Real Madrid
venicius Jr gave rail the lead
and Kevin De bruyne equalized to make it
one all going into the second leg next
week
[Applause]
now it's been described as Ukraine's
party but in the UK's house Liverpool
tonight hosted the first semi-final of
the Eurovision song contest because of
the ongoing war with hundreds of
ukrainians looking on also in the
audience dozens of super fans in full
costume some of them have been speaking
to Katarina bitotsi about the show's
enduring appeal
foreign
[Music]
pool
right now this is the only place you'll
find opera singers doing Abba
or a roller skating jellyfish
[Music]
but shall we be surprised after all this
is the home of Eurovision and the super
fans have arrived the mix of cultures
languages and it's so calm we just love
it very calm a great great mix of music
yeah just so different every every time
I'm here all week Liverpool knows how to
throw a party so bring it on
and this is why they're here
it's on contest 2022 3
this was the first semi-final
featuring The sweeter
the sexy
and the sublimely strange
by the end the public voted 10 out of 15
acts through to Saturday's final
[Applause]
what's the ticket in the arena is the
hottest seat in town there are big
screens across the city and in bars like
this one because Eurovision is big
business is the largest non-sporting
event in the world with an audience
of the American Super Bowl obviously
it's been such a good boost and it's
been really good for business
um yeah it has really helped obviously
over the past few years not been easy
but um yeah it's just been brilliant
there's nobody work for it apart I'm
just brilliant really
it's brilliant the Eurovision way with
extra glitter and a whole lot of glam
[Music]
Katrina fertazzi Sky News Liverpool